In fact, why don't you take up the opportunity? Why,
why would you come and make your fortune here in South Africa when,
as you've described, that you could be making a fortune in Zimbabwe?
Why are you here? Because I'm part of the problem in Zimbabwe.
My attitude of thinking
I had to come and take up the opportunity that was offered to me here.
So why don't you go home instead of my name?
May I ask you that? Why I am going home right now.
I've also got family in South Africa.
I've got South African children.
And those South African children
don't just allow me to just stand up and leave.
But I do have projects that I'm taking apart in,
in Zimbabwe,
because I've learnt that those resources are the most important thing.
If you have such faith in your country,
in Zimbabwe,
I would say,
and I would think you would get up and you would take your family
and you were going to fix up the future of Zimbabwe.
If you're saying there's land,
if you're saying there's minerals,
if you're saying there is so much wealth and opportunities for you
there, you're living a contradiction.
No, I'm not living in contradiction. You,
you set me up by sitting here.
I would ask you that. Why,
cause people are suffering in Zimbabwe.
So why are people not, why are people not going to the Netherlands?
Why are people not, Germans not going back to Germany,
is it because their countries are bad?
Is it because they're running away from problems in the UK or in the,
in the States? Why aren't Europeans going?
What are you doing here? I live here.
This is my home. I'm not running away from it.
Why are you living here instead of Europe?
Why did your great grandparents come here instead of Europe?
We're not talking about grandparents.
We're talking about me. No,
you've made it sound like a Zimbabwe
needs to go back to Zimbabwe to show that Zimbabwe is working.
So why are Europeans not going back to Europe?
Why are Asians not going back to Asia?
Why are they staying in Africa?
The context of the conversation is that
you're saying that Zimbabwe is a beautiful country
with great opportunities
and people have run away from there to become waiters.
The context is you are living here in South Africa
when you could be going back and making that country work.
That's the. That.
You also forgot that. You also forgot that I was asked to come here.
Somebody thought my skills were important here.
I've been asked to go to other countries,
but I believe in this country.
But why don't you believe in Europe?
No, I believe in South Africa.
Why don't you believe in Europe?
I believe in my country. Why don't you believe in USA? This is not about.